[Music]
you are looking at the tomb of the
unknown soldier in arlington national
cemetery this morning this veterans day
marks the 100th anniversary of the day
the first unknown soldier was laid to
rest there in 1921 then president warren
g harding delivered a famous speech as
part of the dedication ceremony he
eulogized the anonymous soldier who died
fighting in world war one let's revisit
the words of our 29th president recited
by the members of the military the
sentinels who guard the tomb as they
reflect on what service and sacrifice
means to them
[Music]
november 11th november 11th
mr secretary of war and ladies and
gentlemen we are met today to pay the
impersonal tribute
the name of him whose body lies before
us took flight with his imperishable
soul
we know not whence he came
but only that his death marks him with
the everlasting glory of an american
dying for his country
our mission is twofold one to maintain a
continuous
ceremonial guard and watch over the tomb
of the unknown soldier
and the second aspect is to ensure that
every visitor
from this nation from every nation
witnesses the highest standards and
traditions of not only the united states
army but this nation
so the first day i changed the guard
was roughly four and a half months ago
and i have honestly never been more
scared in my life
as i stood in front of the door
one of the my fellow staff sergeants
came up to me and said the reason you're
nervous is because you care so hold on
to that
we do not know his station in life
because from every station came the
patriotic response of the five millions
we do not know the eminence of his birth
but we do know the glory of his death he
died for his country and greater
devotion hath no man than this
he may have been a native or an adopted
son that matters little because they
glorified the same loyalty
they sacrificed alike
i immigrated to the united states when i
was two years old
and
i wanted to give back to my country
and service called me we call it walking
the mat when when i walk the mat
not only am i thinking about my 21
seconds and 21 steps which is symbolic
of the 21 gun salute and we're always
rendering honors to those unknown
soldiers
i think about the unknowns i think about
their sacrifice their families
it is a lot to carry with us
but it's a responsibility someone has to
take
we take our job very seriously
we have been guarding continuously since
midnight to july 1937.
on november 11th 2021
we will be guarding the tomb
continuously 24 7 for 30 814 days
snow sleet
whether it be heavy winds or
hail or god forbid tornadoes or
hurricanes we're we're still expected to
go out there and do the same job to the
same level of proficiency we still go
about conducting the mission the same
way because at the end of the day the
mission is still the same
on the threshold of eternity many a
soldier i can well believe wondered how
his ebbing blood would color the stream
of human life flowing on after his
sacrifice
indeed i revere that citizen whose
confidence in the righteousness of his
country
inspired belief that its triumph is the
victory of humanity
you know
back when the tomb was first constructed
people used to come and before it was
guarded they would take pieces of the
tomb as a bit of closure
to take home as the unknown soldier
could be their brother or their father
or somebody in their family who never
returned from war and so i like to think
about that often
we always say that what we do here is it
acts as a continuous funeral service
that will be going on as long as any of
us are capable to keep doing the job
today's ceremonies proclaim that the
hero unknown is not unhonored we gather
him to the nation's breast within the
shadow of the capital of the towering
shaft that honors washington the great
father and of the exquisite monument to
lincoln the martyred savior
on such an occasion as this amid such a
scene our thoughts alternate between
defenders living and defenders dead
a grateful republic will be worthy of
them both
our part is to atone for the losses of
heroic dead by making a better republic
for the living
i like what the one soldier said when he
was told the reason why you're nervous
is because you care hold on to that
there's so much you feel that so much
it's quotable in that and it all goes
back to world war one 100 years ago in
fact veterans day itself 11th hour of
the 11th month armistice day is supposed
to be the war to end all wars of course
it was not and that's why we pay our
respects and also express our gratitude
on a day like today unknown but not on
our we'll never forget talking about
caring matt allen and camille douglas
special shout out to you the producers
that put that together it's very hard to
do that guys viewers who are listening
to put a piece that beautifully done
with no track nicely done guys thank you
both